Estoy muy feliz de estar entre algunos de los más
-las luces me están molestando
y se reflejan en las gafas.
Estoy muy feliz y es un honor estar entre
gente muy, muy innovadora e inteligente.
He escuchado a los tres ponentes anteriores,
¿y saben qué pasó?
Cada cosa que iba a decir, la han dicho ellos,
y parece que no tengo nada más que decir.
(Risas)
Pero hay un dicho en mi cultura
que dice que si la flor abandona el árbol sin decir nada,
es que es una flor joven.
Así que hablaré -ya que no soy joven, soy muy viejo-
Aún así diré algo.
Celebramos esta conferencia en un momento muy oportuno
porque hay otra conferencia ahora en Berlín,
la Cumbre del G8.
La Cumbre del G8 propone que la solución a los problemas de África
debería ser un aumento masivo de ayuda,
algo parecido al Plan Marshall.
Por desgracia, yo no creo en el Plan Marshall.
Porque han exagerado los beneficios del Plan Marshall.
Sus principales destinatarios fueron Alemania y Francia,
y supuso solo un 2,5% de su PIB.
Un país africano medio recibe ayuda extranjera
que llega al 13,15% de su PIB,
y esto es una transferencia inaudita de recursos financieros
de países ricos a países pobres.
Pero quiero decir que necesitamos relacionar dos cosas:
la manera en que los medios muestran a África en occidente, y las consecuencias de eso.
Al mostrar desesperanza, impotencia y desaliento,
los medios dicen la verdad y nada más que la verdad.
Sin embargo, los medios no nos dicen toda la verdad.
Porque la desesperanza, la guerra civil y el hambre,
a pesar de que son una parte de nuestra realidad africana,
no son la única realidad.
Y, en segundo lugar, son la realidad más pequeña.
África tiene 53 naciones.
Tenemos guerras civiles sólo en seis países,
lo que significa que los medios cubren sólo seis países.
África tiene inmensas oportunidades que nunca navegan
por la red de la desesperanza y el desánimo
que los medios occidentales mayormente presentan a su audiencia.
Pero el efecto de esa presentación llama a la simpatía,
llama a la pena, llama a algo llamado caridad.
Y, como consecuencia, la visión occidental
del dilema económico de África está mal enmarcada.
El marco erróneo es un producto del pensamiento
de que África es un lugar de desesperanza.
¿Qué debemos hacer respecto a eso? Debemos alimentar al hambriento,
debemos dar medicina a los enfermos,
debemos enviar tropas que mantengan la paz
para servir a los que se enfrentan a una guerra civil.
Y en el proceso África ha sido despojada de iniciativa propia.
Quiero decir que es importante reconocer
que África tiene debilidades esenciales.
Pero, de la misma manera, tiene oportunidades y mucho potencial.
Necesitamos reformular el reto que afronta África
de un reto de desesperanza,
desesperanza llamada "reducción de la pobreza",
a un reto de esperanza.
Lo formulamos como un reto de esperanza: creación de valor.
El reto que afrontan los que se interesan en África
no es el reto de reducir la pobreza.
Debería ser un reto de crear riqueza.
Una vez cambiemos esas dos cosas
-si decís que los africanos son pobres y que hay que reducir la pobreza,
teneis el cártel internacional de buenas intenciones
entrando en el continente, ¿con qué?
medicinas para los pobres, comida para los hambrientos,
y tropas de paz para los que están en guerra civil.
Y en el proceso, ninguna de estas cosas son productivas en realidad
porque estais tratando los síntomas, no las causas
de los problemas esenciales de África.
Enviar a alguien al colegio y darles medicinas,
señoras y señores, no les crea riqueza.
La riqueza viene en función de los ingresos, y los ingresos vienen
de una oportunidad de negocio rentable y de un trabajo bien remunerado.
Bien, ahora que ya hemos hablado de crear riqueza en África,
nuestro segundo reto será:
¿Quiénes son los agentes que crean riqueza en una sociedad?
Son empresarios. Nos dicen que siempre suponen
alrededor de un 4% de la población, pero el 16% son imitadores.
Aún así, ellos también tienen éxito como emprendedores.
¿Así que dónde debemos poner el dinero?
Debemos poner el dinero dónde pueda crecer productivamente.
Apoyar la inversión privada en África, tanto nacional como extranjera.
Apoyar las instituciones de investigación,
porque el conocimiento es una parte importante de la creación de riqueza.
¿Pero qué ésta haciendo la comunidad de ayuda internacional con África hoy en día?
Están arrojando grandes sumas de dinero para asistencia médica básica,
para educación primaria y para comida.
Todo el continente se ha convertido en
un lugar de desesperanza, necesitado de caridad.
Señoras y señores, ¿puede alguno de vosotros nombrarme
a un vecino, un amigo, o un pariente que conozcan
que se haya hecho rico recibiendo caridad?
¿Por sostener un bote y recibir limosnas?
¿Alguno del público conoce a esa persona?
¿Alguien conoce un país que se desarrollara a causa
de la generosidad y amabilidad de otro?
Bueno, como no veo ninguna mano,
parece que lo que estoy diciendo es cierto.
Bono: ¡Sí!
Veo que Bono dice que conoce el país.
¿Qué país es ese?
Bono: Tiene nombre irlandés.
(Risas)
Bono: [ininteligible]
Muchas gracias, pero déjame decirte esto:
los actores externos solo te presentan una oportunidad.
La habilidad de utilizar esa oportunidad y de convertirla en una ventaja
depende de tu capacidad interna.
África ha recibido muchas oportunidades,
muchas de ellas no nos han beneficiado demasiado.
¿Por qué? Porque carecemos de un marco institucional interno
y de un marco político que hagan posible que nos
beneficiemos de nuestras relaciones externas. Les pondré un ejemplo:
Bajo el Acuerdo de Cotonou,
antes conocido como la Convención de Lomé,
Europa les daba a los países africanos la oportunidad
de exportar productos sin impuestos, al mercado de la Unión Europea.
Mi país, Uganda, tiene un cupo para exportar 50.000 toneladas
de azúcar al mercado de la Unión Europea.
No hemos exportado todavía ni un kilo.
Importamos 50.000 toneladas de azúcar de Brasil y Cuba.
En segundo lugar, bajo el protocolo, relacionado con la carne vacuna, de ese acuerdo,
los países africanos que producen carne de vaca
tienen cupos para exportar carne, sin impuestos, al mercado de la Unión Europea.
Ninguno de esos países, incluida la nación más próspera, Botswana,
ha cubierto nunca su cupo.
Así que hoy quiero argumentar que la fuente esencial de la incapacidad
de África para conectar con el resto del mundo
en una relación más productiva,
se debe a un marco político e institucional pobre.
Y todas las formas de intervención necesitan apoyo,
la evolución de los tipos de instituciones que crean riqueza,
los tipos de instituciones que aumentan la productividad.
¿Cómo empezamos a hacer esto y por qué la ayuda es un mal instrumento?
La ayuda es un mal instrumento, ¿y saben por qué?
Porque todos los gobiernos del mundo necesitan dinero para sobrevivir.
Hace falta dinero para algo tan simple como mantener la ley y el orden.
Hay que pagar al ejército y a la policia para mostrar ley y orden.
Y como muchos de nuestros gobiernos son bastante dictatoriales,
verdaderamente necesitan que el ejército derrote a la oposición.
Lo segundo que hay que hacer es pagar a tus parásitos políticos.
¿Por qué debería el pueblo apoyar a su gobierno?
Bien, porque les da trabajos bien remunerados,
o, en muchos países africanos, oportunidades extraoficiales
para beneficiarse de la corrupción.
El hecho es que ningún gobierno del mundo,
a excepción de unos pocos como el de Idi Amin,
pueden depender por completo de la fuerza como instrumento de gobierno.
Muchos países en el [ininteligible], necesitan legitimidad.
Para obtener legitimidad, los gobiernos necesitan proporcionar cosas como educación primaria,
sanidad básica, carreteras, contruir hospitales y clínicas.
Si la supervivencia fiscal del gobierno
depende de hacer que aumente el dinero de su propio pueblo.
dicho gobierno está motivado por el interés propio
de gobernar de una manera más progresista
Se reunirá con los que crean riqueza.
Les hablará de los tipos de políticas e instituciones
que son necesarias para que se extiendan a escala y ámbito de negocio,
y así poder recaudar más ingresos tributarios de ellos.
El problema del continente africano,
y el problema con la industria de la ayuda,
es que ha distorsionado la estructura de los incentivos
que afrontan los gobiernos en África.
El margen productivo en la búsqueda de rentas por parte de nuestro gobierno
no se sustenta en la economía nacional,
se sustenta en los donantes internacionales.
En vez de reunirse con ugandeses--
(Aplausos)
En vez de reunirse con empresarios ugandeses,
hombres de negocios ghaneses, líderes emprendedores sudafricanos,
nuestros gobiernos encuentran mas productivo
hablar con el FMI y el Banco Mundial.
Puedo deciros, incluso si tenéis diez doctorados,
que nunca superaréis a Bill Gates en el entendimiento de la industria informática.
¿Por qué? Porque el conocimiento requerido para que entendáis
los incentivos necesarios para expandir un negocio,
requiere que escuchéis a la gente, a los actores del sector privado en esa industria.
La comunidad internacional les ha dado a los gobiernos en África
la oportunidad de evitar establecer
acuerdos productivos con sus propios ciudadanos,
y por tanto, ha permitido empezar negociaciones interminables con el FMI
y el Banco Mundial, y entonces es el FMI y el Banco Mundial
quienes dicen lo que los ciudadanos necesitan.
En el transcurso, nosotros, los africanos, hemos sido marginados
del proceso de elaboración, orientación e implementación
de la política en nuestros países.
Tenemos una aportación limitada porque quien paga, manda.
El FMI, el Banco Internacional, y el cártel de buenas intenciones en el mundo
se han apoderado de nuestros derechos como ciudadanos,
y por tanto lo que nuestros gobiernos están haciendo, porque dependen de ayudas,
es escuchar a los acreedores internacionales en vez de a sus propios ciudadanos.
Pero quiero hacer una aclaración sobre mi argumentación,
y esa aclaración es que no es cierto que la ayuda sea siempra destructiva.
Alguna ayuda puede haber construido un hospital, alimentado a una aldea hambrienta.
Puede haber construido una carretera, y esa carretera
puede haber desempeñado un muy buen papel.
El error de la industria de la ayuda internacional
es coger esos incidentes de éxito aislados,
generalizarlos, invertir billones y trillones de dólares en ellos,
y luego propagarlos alrededor del mundo,
ignorando las circunstancias específicas y únicas en una villa determinada,
las habilidades, las prácticas, las normas y hábitos
que permiten que ese pequeño proyecto de ayuda tenga éxito
-- como en la aldea Sauri en Kenia dónde está trabajando Jeffrey Sachs --
y por lo tanto, generalizar esa experiencia
como la experiencia de todos.
La ayuda aumenta los recursos disponibles para los gobiernos,
y eso hace que trabajar en un gobierno sea lo más rentable
que puedas tener como africano que busca una carrera.
Al aumentar el atractivo político del estado,
sobre todo en nuestras sociedades fragmentadas étnicamente en África,
la ayuda tiende a acentuar tensiones étnicas
mientras que cada grupo étnico empieza ahora a luchar por entrar en el estado
para tener acceso al pastel de la ayuda extranjera.
Señoras y señores, la gente más emprendedora de África
no puede encontrar oportunidades para comerciar y trabajar en el sector privado
porque el entorno político e institucional es hóstil hacia los negocios.
Los gobiernos no lo están cambiando. ¿Por qué?
Porque no necesitan hablar a sus propios ciudadanos.
Les hablan a los donantes internacionales.
Así que los africanos más emprendedores terminan trabajando para el gobierno,
y eso ha aumentado las tensiones políticas en nuestros países
precisamente porque dependemos de la ayuda.
También quiero decir que es importante para nosotros
observar que durante los últimos 50 años, África ha estado recibiendo cada vez más ayuda
de la comunidad internacional
en forma de asistencia técnica, ayuda financiera
y todas las otras formas de ayuda.
Entre 1960 y 2003 nuestro continente recibió 600 billones de dólares de ayuda,
y todavía nos dicen que hay mucha pobreza en África.
¿A dónde ha ido toda la ayuda?
Quiero poner el ejemplo de mi propio país, llamado Uganda,
y la clase de estructura de incentivos que la ayuda ha traído allí.
En el presupuesto 2006-2007, los ingresos previstos eran de 2,5 trillones de chelines.
La ayuda esperada: 1,9 trillones.
El gasto recurrente de Uganda -- ¿A qué me refiero con recurrente?
Lo más precario -- es de 2,6 trillones.
¿Por qué el gobierno de Uganda gasta el 100%
de sus propios ingresos?
Es porque hay alguien ahí llamado "ayuda internacional" que contribuye a ello.
Pero esto les demuestra que el gobierno de Uganda
no está comprometido a gastar sus propios ingresos
en invertir en inversiones productivas,
sino que dedica estos ingresos
a pagar la estructura de gasto público.
La administración pública, con su amplio patrocinio, se lleva 690 billones.
La militar, 380 billones.
La agricultura, que da empleo al 18% de nuestros necesitados ciudadanos,
se lleva solo 18 billones.
El comercio y la industria se llevan 43 billones.
Y dejen que les enseñe lo que el gasto público
-- en vez del gasto de la administración pública -- constituye en Uganda.
Allá vamos. 70 ministros en el consejo, 114 asesores presidenciales
quienes, por cierto, nunca ven al presidente, excepto en televisión.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Y cuando lo ven físicamente, es en actos públicos como este,
e incluso ahí, es él quien los asesora a ellos.
(Risas)
Tenemos 81 unidades de gobierno local;
cada gobierno local está organizado como el gobierno central:
una burocracia, un consejo, un parlamento,
y muchos trabajos para los parásitos políticos.
Había 56, y cuando nuestro presidente quiso
corregir la constitución y eliminar los límites de mandato,
tuvo que crear 25 distritos nuevos, y ahora hay 81.
333 miembros del parlamento.
Necesitaís el Wembley Stadium para acoger a nuestro parlamento.
134 comisiones
y cuerpos gubernamentales semi-autónomos,
todos los cuales tienen directores y coches -- y lo último,
esto es dirigido al señor Bono. En su trabajo quizás nos ayude con esto.
Un estudio reciente del gobierno de Uganda reveló
que hay 3.000 vehículos de motor de cuatro ruedas
en la sede del Ministerio de Sanidad.
Uganda tiene 961 subcondados, todos tienen una enfermería,
ninguna de las cuales tiene ambulancia.
Así que los vehículos de cuatro ruedas en la sede
llevan a los ministros, a los secretarios permanentes, a los burócratas
y a los burócratas de la ayuda internacional que trabajan en proyectos de ayuda,
mientras los pobres mueren sin ambulancias ni medicinas.
Finalmente, quiero decir que antes de venir a hablar aquí
me dijeron que el principio de TEDGlobal
es que un buen discurso debe ser como una minifalda,
debe ser sufiente corto para despertar interés,
pero suficiente largo para cubrir el tema.
Espero haberlo conseguido.
(Risas)
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)